[Music]
this is the ramsay show
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsay show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
dr john deloney ramsey personality
best-selling author and host of the dr
john deloney show is my co-host today as
we talk about your life
your money your relationships your
careers and uh talk about you right in
front of you it's a free call at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
some say the advice is worth exactly
what you pay for it triple eight eight
two five five
two two five it's book launch week
around ramsey the new book baby steps
millionaires how ordinary people built
extraordinary wealth and how you can too
is selling at a record pace it's blowing
maybe the fastest selling book i've ever
done i've never seen incredible it's
pretty incredible thank you guys out
there we really appreciate you uh it's
uh zoom zoom we got a big event tonight
with george campbell rachel cruz and me
150 000 people signed up to watch online
1500 will be live in the audience it's
completely free to watch online it is
called building wealth in 2022 and we're
going to tell you how to really do it um
pretty simple stuff obviously it's what
we are specializing in putting the
cookies on the shelf where even i can
reach them so because i like the cookies
and that kind of stuff that's a great
metaphor but the uh so you can sign up
for that if you want to be one of the
people watching it online tonight it
starts at 7 p.m central time at
ramseysolutions.com wealth well we
launched borrowed future you were
featured in the documentary borrowed
future our goal with borrowed future was
to stir up a holy ruckus
and expose the misbehavior of the entire
student loan debacle from the higher ed
people to the banks to the
navients to the sallie maes to the
freaking congress that's lost their mind
the student loan thing is completely out
of control borrowed futures now been
viewed by over 150 000 people and is
booming too thank you guys for watching
it you can watch that on amazon prime
anytime you'd like and today it comes
out navient uh this from the new york
times reaches a 1.85
billion dollar deal
to settle claims of predatory
behavior
that's a lot of money 1.85 billion
hey it's really important that we note
dave
they didn't do anything wrong yeah
yeah that's that's what's this is one of
the largest settlements i've ever seen
in my life of anything the government is
sued
government sues somebody they usually
get a little money for the people
they're suing on behalf of
uh
1.85
billion
dollars
and uh
mark colleen naviance chief legal
officer
who's about as full of crap as anybody
i've ever read
quote was the company decision to
resolve these matters which were based
on unfounded claims allows us to avoid
the additional burden expense time and
distraction to prevail in court
honey you don't give up 1.85 billion
with a b if you think there's a
snowball's chance you're going to
prevail in court
you might give up 100 million
but not 1.85
billion
that's a billion is a thousand million
that's 1800 000 million
oh my gosh 1800 million i took a day off
of work to go sit in court over a 200
ticket one time that i thought i was
right on 1.8 billion dollars no it was
somebody else it was it was other kids
now the other kids naviate which did not
admit any fault in the settlement said
it did not act illegally
course you acted illegally you don't
give up 1.85 billion just predators in
your settlement if you didn't do that
now here's how here's how wild these
figures are okay now to date uh these
numbers are a little bit old so i will i
will take a pass on this but on my
little cheat sheet here
to date just under 4 000 borrowers
250 000 people have applied
for private student loan forgiveness
okay under the 10-year private student
loan forgiveness plan okay
4 000 people out of the 250 000 were
actually granted the forgiveness yeah at
an average of 87 000 a piece
so
here's the irony of this okay the entire
private student loan forgiveness program
has now forgiven
way less than navient
see they weren't they weren't bad people
they're they're they left they're trying
to be nice
this was their controversial humanity
they just didn't just they're just
generous that way these navient people
they're just it's kind and lovely that
you know that that that little sally may
thing that thing they had in maui where
they all had a little getaway to
celebrate how many people they'd screwed
that that really didn't come up oh wow
yeah so the deal announced thursday
requires navient to cancel 1.7 billion
in private student loans which is about
4x what the entire private student loan
forgiveness program has ever done and
they had a little bit of a little bitty
fine of another 100 million dollars yeah
95 million in restitution but they
didn't do anything wrong that's right
they're just
it's just
1.7 billion in forgiven loans that means
they were proven to have screwed those
people yeah taking advantage of people
that didn't know what they were doing
this is a black black business we are in
people
this whole student loan thing
and if you lefties want to keep talking
about giving forgiving student loans and
the biden administration is going to
forgive student loans and all that
that's great
before you actually enter that
discussion with integrity though you
have to stop making them
yeah what's the plan there that's like
saying hey sheila though you're asking
me i was just thinking like was that a
rhetorical question okay hey john that's
kind of generally at the universe what's
the plan yeah we're still in there i
don't understand it because we're going
to keep making them so that there's more
people we're going to forgive them
january 1 and then all these students
will enroll the next semester and
keep okay i did see this i saw this data
point today one million fewer college
students are enrolled this semester
well i mean the lowest in 50 years let
me tell you what's happening big time i
mean this yale lawsuit came up this week
too where there's about 10 or 15 of
these
yale mit brown they're all sued for
using for colluding on their prices
uh so higher ed's getting another black
eye especially the famous college right
the muckety mucks right they're getting
another black eye on screwing their
their own people over their own students
over but you got a million people saying
i'm going to study online i'm going to
stay at home i'm just going to get a job
what do you think about it i mean the
guy called up here the day from michigan
state and said uh he goes
i just signed up for all my classes and
then they canceled them all and said
they're all online he goes i want my
money back well yeah i'll go to college
cancel them yeah and go if you're going
to take online don't pay
you know all that price for that
absolutely cancel them all get your
money back and that's what's happening
these guys have forgotten that they are
in the business of serving the student
um
arrogant yeah beyond belief and we're
just going to cove to shut it down and
we're going to charge you anyway so
although the students are going i don't
think so i think i'm just not going to
come let's try that a consultant came
and spoke to us you may have even heard
this story before
um came and talked to us at a university
i worked at once and
said that um told us it was a parable of
some sort about
a drill bit company that was selling
drill bits had a record drill bit year
and the the ceo was talking about how
many drill bits they'd sold and they'd
sold a bunch of drill bits and they were
heroes
and then the president got up and
quietly said
i want to never forget we're not in the
drill bit business we're in the hole
making business and somebody's gonna go
make a hole cheaper and faster and
better than us than our drill bits we
better be careful and higher education
has to realize we're in the education
business
not in the making ourselves look bigger
and better business well not making
ourselves look like we are covet
politically correct
whatever we're all worried about all
worried about the audience absolutely
politically correct on something else
maybe you ought to be teaching somebody
something i don't know there's an idea
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
still on baby step number one huh
how'd you guess
with health care costs rising learn how
christian healthcare ministries can help
you make the most out of your budget
visit ch chministries.org budget don't
worry it's worth it
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
dr john deloney ramsey personality is my
co-host tonight
today tonight we are doing
building wealth 2022 with rachel cruz
george campbell and i we're going to
talk about the fastest
right way
to build wealth
there's a lot of fast ways but the
fastest right way
there's a lot of slow ways
but the fastest right way
tonight at 7 pm central time it is sold
out has been sold out for some time but
you can't sell the internet out so you
can watch live online with a live stream
completely free and if you don't like
what you see we'll give you half your
money back it's completely free
so uh go to ramseysolutions.comwealth
and register and we'd love to have you
all right let's go to kevin in los
angeles hi kevin welcome to the ramsey
show
thanks dave uh just a quick question
when choosing a mutual fund how much
weight should i give ratings from
websites like morningstar.com
so for instance i'm i was looking at two
different mutual funds and their
performance over the past 10 years one
of them looked like it had been doing
slightly better than the other but
morningstar gave it three stars where
the other had five stars should i factor
that in when choosing
morningstar's rating is risk adjusted
and so they're p they're pulling up the
beta the volatility of the fund
uh and adjusting on that probably that's
how they used to do it i haven't
subscribed to them in a long time
uh when i was back back when i was in
the business and then when i first
started on the radio i kept morningstar
on my computer before there was an
internet
we used to get cd rom updates quarterly
on them and uh so they're an old rating
system they've been rating mutual funds
a long time but if i remember correctly
they're risk adjusted and that may
explain it if you'll go pull the what's
called the beta the beta is the
statistical measure of risk
and you'll probably find that three star
has a higher beta that to get to a
slightly better rate of return it went
through higher peaks and lower valleys
does that make sense to you
yeah that does make sense i'm guessing
but i'm guessing but i'll bet you that's
what you find
yeah it looked like the other things
that were factoring in were things like
how often the fund manager shifted and
stuff like that so like not just
volatility in the market of the fund but
like the volatility of the management of
the funds
they would they would look at that as
well that does make sense so it could be
that in addition to the beta now here's
the thing uh if you're looking at fund
volatility based on management there's
uh
more and more of the funds have gone to
a team
management style rather than a singular
rock star manager
that way they're not as dependent on
that one guy
for their future returns in other words
if you had a history of 10 years of
great returns and it was a rock star
manager model not a team model managing
it and the rockstar guy leaves well the
track record kind of leaves with him
right
but if you've got a team model and two
of the 15 people running the fund uh
that are the brains causing the return
to happen over the last 10 years leave
well you're probably can say
that that history is probably valid for
projecting into the future common sense
wise anyway and so a lot of the funds
have gone away from rockstar managers
for that reason and they've gone to team
management because that validates their
their historical returns that way into
the future and can project them into the
future but you just look at that i
honestly i mean i'll glance at that kind
of stuff i am mainly looking at the
track record and is there some reason
that the track record isn't valid
because the whole team left or there's a
complete turnover in style or a
philosophy shift in the management or
something like that unless there's
something that invalidates the track
record
i'm spending like 85 percent of my issue
when i'm picking a fund on track record
i'll look at the volatility i look at
the other stuff i look at the expense
ratios i look at all the other stuff but
it's a very small percentage of how much
time i spend
on that kind of thing and kevin i'll
tell you one other thing the fact that
you're asking these questions means
you're going to win and here's let me
give you the reason why
there's a a group of actuarial nerds
that studies retirement stuff
and it's like 17 initials i can't
remember the name of it but i was
looking at one of their studies not long
ago
and they found that 78
of the
predictive
reason for someone
becoming wealthy using an investment
is
savings rate
now let me translate that what that
means is 78 of the way you can predict
whether someone makes a bunch of money
in an investment is if they actually
invest
that's what that means no
how expensive was that study
gee and the point being though that this
group of nerds figured out that
you know this nuanced stuff of a beta or
an expense ratio
or team versus rockstar doesn't matter
put money into a retirement just will
freaking do it
you're just like gonna win okay i mean
compared to the people who over analyze
and don't do anything
right and so you don't get caught up in
paralysis of the analysis kevin get er
done baby that's the moral of the story
so i spend a certain amount of time in
looking at this stuff and if one of them
starts tanking on me i may move it but
i'm just putting it in there yeah when
in doubt when in doubt swing the bat or
you ain't gonna hit the ball i mean this
is like rock it's just the funniest
thing i've ever read because because
people in the business they all get mad
at dave ramsey because he's too
primitive and he doesn't actually
understand doesn't have the intellect to
grasp all of the nuances of the
investing world
yeah obviously i don't uh but but you
know and so but the truth is 78 has to
do with whether you actually did it
i saw that the other day someone was
asking some some fitness people what's
the best workout what's the best workout
and finally one guy snapped and said
anyone that you will do that's the best
one the one you don't quit keep doing it
the one that you don't quit doing get in
the game yeah
this is some genius advice we're doling
out here man i'm telling you we get the
big bucks john's in greenville south
carolina hey john what's up
hey guys there we go better than i
deserve man how can we help
good uh all right so me and my wife are
both 26 uh under 26. i'm 24 she's 23. we
are expecting our first child a girl
and
yeah we're super excited life's getting
ready to rock
i know i'm telling you but uh so we're
both still on our parents insurance and
it's great insurance on both sides we're
wondering how do we get the baby covered
and what do we need to do to get set up
so that when the baby comes it's taken
care of as far as insurance
ew so your parents
does your parents insurance cover your
maternity delivery
it covers so it covers everything up to
delivery it is all it covers all the
prenatal stuff but as soon as the baby
is born
uh it won't cover uh
our dependent then so but i mean you and
your you and your wife are on two
different insurance plans right now
right
yes and both of them are that way
yes sir wow
do you all work
we do we vote for do you not have
insurance at work
no sir we're both we're both working for
companies that are small enough that
they haven't they haven't gotten uh
health insurance programs yet okay two
different things then we need to address
one is i don't think you're gonna get
insurance on a pregnancy that's already
on the way nope
okay
okay that's known as a pre-existing
condition
um and so you can check with your
insurance while you're shopping so first
thing is i want you to start shopping
for health insurance for you and your
wife
and the open market and you need to buy
it you're like grown-ups with a kid and
stuff so you need to get off mommy's
plan
all right obviously mommy's plan has too
much limitations and doesn't cover you
and a normal plan will cover normal
labor and delivery these days
so just just call uh you can jump on
with our elps for health insurance shop
around get the best deal in your state
in your area
for insurance for a young couple with a
baby and you need just you just need
your own health insurance and that'll
cover the next kid
this kid's gonna come out of pocket
what do you guys make
uh not a whole lot uh at this point but
we've got savings and we've how much
savings do you have
uh
about 5500 okay
i want you to see if you can schedule a
meeting with a hospital administrator
where the baby will be delivered now
go down and meet with them and say i
want to prepay because i'm having to pay
cash for this how much of a discount do
i get if i prepay
you will usually find a 50 to a 70
discount if you pre-pay in cash
because labor and delivery is one of the
few times people like going to the
hospital
and so it's actually pr for them they
like for you to come there and they like
to get prepaid because otherwise they
don't get paid usually
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
if you're not using puretalk for your
wireless you're paying too much puretalk
gives you the same great 5g coverage on
the same 5g network as one of the big
guys for half the cost the average
family saves over
a year go to puretalk.com and choose the
affordable plan that's right for you
with their 30-day risk-free guarantee
you have nothing to lose go to
puretalk.com and enter the promo code
ramsey to save 50 off your first month
[Music]
[Music]
dr john dolone ramsey personality is my
co-host today welcome to the ramsey show
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt free stage rafael is with us hey
rafael amy i'm great how are you better
than i deserve welcome where do you live
i am from uh columbia south carolina
awesomeness welcome to nashville that's
a great town
and all the way over here to do a
debt-free scream how much did you pay
off i paid off uh 77
300 in two years and seven months way to
go and your range of income during that
time
uh it started off at 50 to 500
and uh right now i still have to fill
out my 1099 form but i'm guessing it's
between 85 and 100. good for you
way to go man what do you do for a
living i am a statistician at the south
carolina department of public safety and
i'm also a business owner as well what
do you what kind of business have you
got it is an ebay uh store where i go
yard sale and thrifting and then flip it
online ah
what's doing the best what are you
making the most on flipping ooh i might
get in trouble if i answer that
okay okay
somebody
somebody else will go do it somebody
else
i won't make you reveal your trade
secrets but i was talking to a lady the
other day a single mom who started doing
that and she was buying used clothes
for a dime
yeah and flipping them for a buck 50.
that's one way to do it i mean little
bitty numbers but huge margins yeah it
adds up and just doing and she's doing
making like 10 000 bucks a month profit
i mean she's hot
just killing it man just killing it way
to go
look at you what kind of debt was your
77 000 uh it was student loans and a
personal loan uh
the breakdown i believe is
hundred
66
thirteen in student loans
and the difference ten thousand eight
hundred and eighty seven in the personal
okay
so what's your degree in
uh
i have a
math degree two math degrees uh and a
biostatistics degree i went to a bunch
of school for 10 years so yeah i think
he's smart yeah i can i think he's going
to uh i think stubborn
what's up
i think rafael's a smart guy
way to go man look at you that's so cool
okay so after all of that math and all
that debt
somehow that's oxymoron again it can be
uh you look up and something happens two
years and seven months ago and you said
game on i'm cleaning this message tell
me about it so uh flashback to my first
graduate school for my math degree that
was when my parents first gave me uh the
total money makeover book
and you know i read through it and i
wasn't paying my loans at that time and
you know i read it and i'm like oh yeah
this makes sense i agree with all this i
don't have a credit card
uh i don't spend too much and um
at the at the time when i first read it
to me it was a light read it is lot yeah
it's a very light read and especially
for people like you correct for a
statistician
and uh flash forward to my last school
that i went to and when i graduated
there that's when of course the payments
kick in and that's where
real life hits and i was fortunate and
blessed enough to land a job right after
graduation that's the department of
public safety
and a great job
and however
i was making the regular payments not
knowing where those payments were going
and i guess you know you can say i was
living the normal life
of just doing month by month
and then the pandemic hit and student
loan interest was deferred indefinitely
and at that moment i thought to myself
man i could either
stay at home and play video games you
know all the social life is gone
or i can do something else and make more
money and at the same time that's when
two things happen the first thing is
when i came across your youtube channel
and that was the real one that hit me
because i started seeing all these
people calling in about their student
loans
and a bunch of people panicking and i'm
thinking to myself oh mine's my loan's
not that bad but then the more videos i
i listen i got hooked immediately
i started thinking to myself
maybe they mine are that bad i just
don't know about it and um
yeah and i logged into my account for
the first time
uh and realized how much interest i was
losing or how much money i was losing to
interest and uh
i was like whoa okay you know i've been
in school for 10 years for math and i'm
just figuring out these numbers now yeah
that matters
it's a little embarrassing but uh it was
good for me
okay so tell me about that because
that's a question people have is the
math is complicated it's hard how does
somebody with your
the horsepower you got upstairs
what's the gap between what you know
theoretically in the application in your
own house at the at your time and i ask
you this like i know marriage counselors
get divorced right so it's the same kind
of thing
what's that gap i mean mathematically it
all made sense but i was also a college
student at the time and like most
college students you just don't worry
about it you just sent in the check so
it's
you know there's a smart side of you and
then there's just
the normal person that you are so so you
brought those together yeah i brought
this together and um
that game on so and at the same time as
your youtube videos that's when i
started watching
uh you know videos after work about this
reselling business and um so shout out
to part-time pickers and the cincinnati
picker they're the two godfathers for me
that taught me this business
and just like i got hooked onto y'all's
youtube channel i got hooked onto that
business as well and i i spent six hours
after work just binge watching and
watching them how to do this trade
and
yeah six months in the into the pandemic
after watching both y'all for half a
year i'm like you know what i'm just
gonna do this myself
and it was slow at the start but
oh my gosh like i love it um
good for you yeah both well
channels all right so what do you tell
people now that you've done it all
you've got you're actually a
practitioner it's no longer theory you
knocked it off you paid out seventy
seven thousand dollars
what is the secret to getting out of
debt
first of all you got to know what you're
what mess you got yourself into uh
and once again like
there's a problem that's like 12 steps
first we have to admit there's a problem
that's the hard one because you know
you're sending these checks you're
thinking to yourself
it'll it'll go away but then you look at
what's actually happening and you're
like this is not going to go away for 10
years
so
first of all just identify the problem
and just
be
true to yourself and be like all right
i'm going to get this done
here's the problem here's when i want to
finish it and
it's just reap what you sow
and you know the good news is the math
is not complicated no
they try to make it look like it is uh i
think that's oh big hairy jump big hairy
trunks place the thing off man that's
that simple
hey as a fellow nerd there's nothing
more humbling than picking up a book and
thinking oh this is a light read yeah
and then 10 years later you go it kicks
your butt
guy kicked my butt good for you for the
humility and for i love just getting
after it man i'm proud of you man yes so
uh who were your biggest cheerleaders uh
there's a long list uh
first and foremost of course is uh
is my faith um
i worked like
14 hours a day if you include my office
job and reselling business
sorry
and um
there's just too much that happened that
that was a coincidence
you know the fact that i found y'all and
uh
and the thrifting videos uh at the
perfect time
and uh just wait i'm not a morning
person but these yard sales start at
like 5 a.m
you became one quick i became one yeah
there's only one person that can put
that fire
so um
yeah so definitely credit goes to god
of course my parents uh
they were a little suspicious when i
first started this reselling business
because uh
i was bringing in a lot of stuff into
into my apartment and they were like
what the
what the
something are you doing and uh but once
they started seeing the results uh they
were definitely on board good for you
man yeah they never they never shamed me
about it yeah and they're here to cheer
you on today yeah senator cool we're
proud of you brother yeah we got a copy
i also have a caitlyn she's my yard sale
buddy uh she yeah she went out with me
for a year uh just yard sailing and um
she's the one who wanted to thrift with
me at first and took me out and exposed
me so definitely to her as well all
right we got a copy of baby steps
millionaires for you that's your next
chapter in your story for sure brother
thank you that's some good math to do
and
easy math still and also total money
makeovers so count it down
77 000 paid off in two years and seven
months
you're debt-free two one i'm debt-free
ah
i love it i love it i love it i love it
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
dr john deloney ramsey personality is my
co-host today as we talk about your life
and your money brandy is with us in
sacramento hi brandy welcome to the
ramsay show
hi dave it's so nice to talk to you you
too what's up um
so me and my husband plan on leaving
california in five years when i can
retire early from the state and start
collecting my pension
so we have sold two of our three homes
and have that money just sitting in the
bank
and with interest rates expected to rise
and inflation going through the roof
where should we invest that money for
the next five years we want to have it
you know available when we're ready to
buy out of state yeah but if it were me
i would put a portion of it if not all
of it in just a simple index fund an s p
500 fund
okay
now what that is is a fund that follows
the stock market exactly
it's not going to do better than the
market or worse than the market it's
going to be exactly following the market
now not the dow jones industrial average
but it's going to follow what the real
market is doing the overall markets the
top 500 stocks according to standard and
poor and that's the snp 500 okay
and so i do that when i'm parking money
and uh it's a conservative mid-range
mutual fund investment it's very
predictable
and it has no uh commissions on it so
you're not going to get you don't you i
don't mind paying a commission when i'm
going long term but when i'm just
sticking in there for a little while and
i'll do that sometimes for a year or two
years not even five but when you do it
for five you're pretty safe because the
market's track record
over five year periods of time is very
very good to make some money and you
don't have to make much here to do
better than
the bank because the bank just doesn't
pay anything
yes
and the good news is you're investing
basically in companies that are
inflation
meaning the the things that they make
and that they provide are the prices are
going up on them so they're reflected in
your returns
so that's what you call a hedge against
inflation when you're investing in the
things that are the elements of
inflation
that make sense yeah
yes it does so you know but now here's
the thing you can what you ought to do
is you ought to uh do a little bit of
study on that and see what the track
record is
and say okay how many periods how many
five year periods of the s p
make money and how many lose money
and you go oh oh you know i could lose
money yeah you could
uh but what's the what's the likelihood
based on that i don't know that number
off the top of my head by the way
um
it's the vast majority make money though
probably ninety percent of the five-year
periods make money but ten percent of
the time you could lose money well based
on that i don't wanna put it all in
there i'm gonna put some in cds okay
that's fine but cds are gonna pay you
one two percent even if rates go up
and uh the rates are not going to go up
to the inflationary levels because we're
sitting you know we may see some
double-digit inflation and so if you're
not making at least
10 on your money you're not going to be
ahead of inflation
follow me
you're taking the risk of inflation
kicking your butt if you don't invest
aggressively enough if you invest too
aggressive you're taking the risk of
actually losing the money does that make
sense
yes so that's that's why i do that's
what i would do with it it's what i do
with mine
uh i just park it there and then any
money that it makes you don't have any
it hardly has any turnover ratio so
there's hardly any taxes on it until you
pull the money out and then if you did
make some money and you pull the money
out it'll be taxed at your capital gains
rate rather than your ordinary income
rate so it's even tax advantaged
in that sense
so
good question thanks for joining us
colette is into tallahassee florida hi
colette how are you
great how are you better than i deserve
what's up
hey so i'm calling because me and my
husband are in baby step two we're going
to be done with that by next month
luckily at that same time we're going to
be getting a bonus from work so that
will help fund towards baby step three
and so we will be out of baby step three
by march so my question is we're kind of
struggling with figuring out what to do
next after we've put 15 into retirement
we don't have any kids but we do have a
mortgage but it's a 30-year so we're
trying to debate if it's worth
refinancing if we plan to have a kid and
maybe move out in like three to five
years yeah
refinancing if you're if you're
interested if your interest rate is high
and the break even is there what's your
interest rate yeah
3.5
might not be worth it
so what's your balance
what's your loan balance
uh it's 206 783 okay so if you went from
3.5 to 2.5 you'd save one percent or 2
000 a year
if your refinance costs are 3 000
you would break even in one and a half
years
and your refinance costs won't be three
thousand dollars they'll be more like
five thousand dollars five or six yeah
so your break-even period is probably
going to be like
two and a half or three years and if
you're gonna move in three years then
maybe it doesn't make sense
in which case you still would pay down
extra on the mortgage you don't have to
refinance to pay extra on it
i'm not debating anything just chunk it
on there it's baby step six is what
you're supposed to be doing because
you're not gonna lose the money i'm not
telling you to spend the money the
money's not going away it's going into
your house
and when you sell your house when you
get ready to move they give you a check
and all that money comes back to you
the best part yeah and you save that
interest on that all that time
three you save three and a half percent
on your money and you can't even put it
in the bank for three and a half
mm-hmm
so pay your house off kiddo pay it off
pay it off fast as you can and if you do
move uh you can just take that money out
there and move it to the next one uh if
you don't move then get paid off
uh because we don't know exactly what's
going to happen in the next three and a
half years none of us do your best laid
plans of mice and men may happen and
they may not
so good question there
i
i don't know
i guess i do the same thing i'm trying
to think there's a lot of stuff i i my
mind plays those tricks too but um
i i
why would the process change
just because we're gonna move
i get i guess right so instead of paying
off my mortgage i'm going to do what
with it spend it yeah i'm going to put
it in i'm going to put it in an
investment yeah i think there's the the
i don't want to put money in my house
and then i might lose it if the house
goes down in value i think you're going
to lose it anyway that's the fear if the
house goes down in value
the amount owed on it does not affect
the value right
so if it goes down value below the
amount you owe you have to write a check
for the difference that's right so you
know it doesn't affect that
it doesn't cause it to go down in value
to because you don't owe much on it
matter of fact it causes it to go up in
value because you're a little bit
stronger in your negotiating skills yeah
you can you can sit down a little bit
longer yeah i'm guessing that's just
people are
thinking about selling a house after
they bought a house and i guess it's
hard i guess it's hard to try to pay
something off emotionally when i know
i'm about to turn off so i'm gonna turn
around flip it i guess i guess that's it
i don't know but i also think dave i
think we
are in a weird moment in history right
now where people are making these plans
they're we're kind of obsessed i got to
go do something i've got to move i've
got to do something because the world's
shaking underneath us and there's
something about
existential crisis that's right and
the first thing we do and we have
exercise we run and that's often not the
right move is you got to sit and assess
and so man i don't see people be still
pay off your house and just let
whatever's shaking out let it shake out
man unless you're in california you can
leave
right
like our friend pat if you're going to
get out of here too late they already
knew that that's right
good gosh
oh the number of people that have left
michigan california and new york have
you seen those migrations i saw the maps
yeah you know it's funny i i it didn't
occur to me oh this is human migration
like this happened all throughout
history where big swaths of people move
here move there for various reasons
that's exactly what's happening with the
numbers we're talking and politics
causes it yeah it's economic purity and
oppression and jobs the weather causes
yeah
i mean the number of people that left
new orleans never went back after
katrina junk man there are cajun
restaurants all over the united states
because of katrina
and uh it's just it just really did
happen i mean it's like for real and uh
because i mean the number of people that
that
you know moved into mississippi
tennessee alabama and houston right
across the street
to get away from at the storm and then
just never went and they just never went
back i mean that's in the dust bowl in
the 30s uh john grisham's book he does
he did a a
fiction book called painted house but
it's the whole outline of the the dust
bowl and the arkansas oklahoma
cotton is just gone
about the time henry ford gets
everything rolling and so these plants
are popping up in detroit
and all these hillbillies moved to
detroit uh i worked the plants that was
a migration that never went back that's
why there's rednecks in detroit
in case you were wondering the moral of
that story
this
is the ramsey show
[Music]
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsay advice in
their life let them know about the
ramsey call of the day podcast it's a
quick hit of advice about life and money
in under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
i'm dave ramsey your host dr john
deloney ramsey personality best-selling
author and host of the dr john dolone
show is my co-host today as we talk
about your relationships your work your
money and you it's a free call at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
that's triple eight eight two five five
two two five jack's with us in san
antonio texas hey jack how are you
i'm doing just fine dave how about you
better than i deserve what's up
man it's so good to talk to you i'm a
huge fan well i'm honored how can we
help thank you for your service
i see on my screen you're an air force
officer
i am i had brand new academy grad i'm a
second lieutenant down here in san
antonio um
so i went to the academy so i've had
exposure to the military for the past
four years came from a military family
one of the most frustrating things to me
about being a member of the military
is seeing how heavily young military
members are marketed at things like
credit cards and loans you had a
midshipman the other day that was
marketed the uh the cadet loan from navy
fed i i can't tell you how many people i
know that are
in the 30 000 range of debt because of
that thing that thing sucks you got john
with you yeah it does you know that
all of you know that financial problems
are one of the leading causes of
depression
and the leading cause of death in the
military in 2022 is suicide well not
22-2 yet but in the last decade
suicide's been one of the leading causes
and depression is one of the leading
causes of suicide and financial crises
are one of the leading causes of
depression and so my question to you
um is how as a young military member
can i
in a way be a disciple of christ and a
disciple of your teachings to hopefully
keep my comrades from falling into that
i mean i've read all your books i i know
where to start i haven't done fpu yet i
need to
um but it's just really challenging
being in a culture of depressed people
that are in a lot of debt and i want
help i'm here to serve and i feel like i
can serve them
immensely more than i might be able to
even serve the country
well man that first and foremost man i
applaud your heart and um there's not a
lot of hearts of service like that and
so i'm i'm grateful for you i'm glad
that you're looking at these problems at
the 30 000 foot view that that some of
these policies that
sometimes are quick fixes to try to help
a thing
turn into long term systemic problems
and i think you're exactly right
i i when i look at mental health and i
back again back up 30 thousand foot view
one of the cornerstones of of a lack of
good mental health is not being in
control or not having autonomy to make
decisions for yourself
and when you owe somebody money you
can't do that so
um right man
um i i a couple things come to mind and
dave i'd love to get your wisdom here
i would be careful about drawing
conclusions about from suicide to debt
um
what's gonna happen is as a young
uh officer who's just out of school
who's just
when you get on some of those
uh
crusades if you will without being fully
informed or
putting people on blast in that way
saying this is causing people to die
that's a good way to get tossed out of a
room real quick as a young guy right
i would love to see you lead by example
teaching an fpu to go through the class
and then lead an fpu class for your
cadets be somebody who walks the talk
and when you see somebody hurting you
hand them a copy of the book we'll even
send you a couple copies you can pass
out to some of your the people on on
base with you but what you're going to
you're going to find as a young leader
people are going to watch what you do
way more than they're going to listen to
the words coming out of your mouth
and the hard thing is
you're gonna want to talk talk talk talk
talk talk talk and be angry and be
indignant i want to see you live this
out
yeah right right i appreciate that
wisdom so the
the stats that you're quoting are
accurate the third largest cause of
discharge
from dishonorable discharge from the
military is financial irresponsibility
and there is a huge tie
between people leaving the military and
the mental health situation and the
financial situation it's a it's a battle
readiness problem
when mama's at home about to get their
car repo'ed
that interferes with your brain
mechanism that you're supposed to be
using in battle correct and uh so it's
it really creates it really creates a
dangerous situation and that's one of
the reasons the military's
has to a degree leaned in on it uh the
chaplaincy program if you didn't know
jack has access to financial peace
university and teaches a military
version of it and um you can check in
with those guys and run along beside
them if you want to and begin to teach
the class i would just tell you this out
all the years we've worked with the
military and we work with them a lot all
the branches
one of the most
um
often heard things that i the things i
hear most often is that someone in the
military says hey i got my money
straightened out because the chaplain or
the officer led financial peace
university the second most often heard
thing is hey my officer who serves me as
my leader
loves me
and has advised me on a lot of things in
my life
my officer spoke into my marriage my
officer spoke into my money and i
learned how to get out of debt because
lieutenant so and so colonel so-and-so
spoke into my life
and but they earned the right to do that
because of the type of leader that they
were
not their position
and
some of the most
competent service oriented leaders
that are um
that are unbelievably humble that i have
ever met are some of the most senior
people in the military that i've ever
met
um i mean i know there's some turkeys
out there too but i'm telling you man
i've walked into rooms where there's 8
000 people in the room i'm getting ready
to speak to them and the guy comes up to
me that's kind of dressed down
but i look on his shoulder and i see
what he's got there on his shoulder and
he's running that whole
stinking thing
and i've talked to everybody else for 45
minutes before i got there and i just
get to meet him for a second and he
didn't want to bother me that's a true
servant right yeah i mean just a whole
vibe on this guy you know and that's if
you're that guy jack
they're going to listen to you yeah and
you've got the chance to have influence
that way by earning that influence what
john was saying um you're the right kind
of dude man i'm so happy that you're
serving
the united states of america i'm proud
to i i'm proud to uh as a taxpayer to
pay your payroll that's right you're a
good man and and i think it's he called
something out that's important to note
um
there is a suicide problem in the
military oh for sure got to take care of
those folks and make it care accessible
to them and make it provide a culture
where they feel okay going to get get
help
and
all of our service men and women need to
know that there are predatory their
entire industry set up whether it's the
the private student loans
if you leave the base any base in the
u.s if you leave the base they're stupid
on both sides of the road for the next
two miles oh my gosh as soon as you
leave the base
stupid just lined up down through there
every dumb human trick in the world is
right there don't do it don't do it
don't do 18 year olds left home for the
first time with their first paychecks
right it's it's just predatory yeah
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
if you're considering a career in
technology i recommend bethel tech and
i'm not alone here's what brendan said
before bethel tech i was driving uber
within four months of graduating i got a
job paying 60 thousand dollars about two
years after that i got a remote job that
pays me a hundred and thirty thousand
dollars all thanks to what i learned at
bethel tech you could be next get
started today at betheltech.net
and get 1 000 to 2500
off of your tuition again it's
betheltech.net
ken coleman
[Music]
well everybody's talking about crypto
everybody's talking about nothing down
real estate
everybody's talking about
robin hood and gamestop and
all these other ways to get rich quick
there's a lot of ways to get rich quick
but there's really only one right way to
get rich fast
we're going to talk about all of it
tonight the wrong ways the right ways
and everything else
and uh if you want to join us you can do
so at
a free live stream this evening at 7 00
p.m central time there'll be about
fifteen hundred folks in the sold out
event sixteen hundred folks
uh but if you wanna watch online you'll
be joining about a hundred and fifty
thousand of your closest friends doing
so
and um
you can watch it for free at
ramseysolutions.com
wealth
and you put in your email address and
allow you to watch the whole thing free
ramsey solutions dot com
slash
wealth for this evening and it's all
about launching the brand new book baby
steps millionaires where we teach you
the quickest right way
to become a millionaire sue is with us
in springfield illinois hi sue welcome
to the ramsay show
hello there hi what's up
well i am 75 years old i recently
retired a couple of weeks ago
congratulations
oh thank you what were you doing
uh i was working for the government okay
cool you didn't want to keep working for
them really
no i'm done with that
i put some money together though in the
deferred comp plan it's qualified money
and i'm planning to roll it over
as soon as possible get it out of their
hands good
and
i know you uh say that it's good to use
aggressive and aggressive growth fun
but i was wondering since i'm 75 should
i be
uh using such aggressive funds
okay how much is in your 457
about 1.2 million look at you guys so
i'm so proud of you
i love it thank you and how much is in
your other 401ks and other stuff
um i'd say about
400 000
okay
all right cool what's your house worth
oh it's a small house probably at the
most it'd probably be
eighty or ninety thousand okay okay
yeah but i'm wow
i've been set free for 50 years you're
just a lo-fi millionaire that's all
years
unbelievable yeah
you are amazing i don't
i don't like loans
i hate interest i love you you're
awesome
[Laughter]
i'm debt-free for just 50 years is all
i'm just oh
a lo-fi
okay so here's the thing
if you spread your
investments across growth growth in
growth and income aggressive growth and
international our standard for
mutual funds sit down with a smart
investor pro and they can show you
the risk analysis on that of
how many times
in the past
30 years would that mix have caused you
to have a down year
they can chart that out for you and you
can learn so you're a student i can tell
and you study that and you learn that if
that scares you
if the number of times that that that
uh
mountain and valley on the graph goes
too low to suit you
in other words you feel risky to you
then take the aggressive growth out of
the mix
and put a balanced fund in there
balance okay and that'll that will calm
this whole portfolio way
down
okay you want to calm it down even
further take the take the uh uh
the overseas fund the foreign fund the
international fund completely out
because you will see when you look at
the data on it that it's had more down
years than all the other three put
together
okay
so uh
that's the way to look at because all
we're doing here is calming the thing
down here's the thing
even if you stayed with the original mix
with 1.27 million dollars
you're not the only thing you're going
to see is just some numbers move around
it's not going to affect your life
it might go up to 1.5 and then it might
go down to 1.4 and then it might go up
to 1.7 and then it might go down to 1.5
and you might see it move around like
that over the years
while you're living out of the income on
it it's 100 plus thousand dollars a year
coming to you if you want it to
uh and you'll still be just fine with
all of that but you may you know you're
just going to have the numbers riding a
bit of a roller coaster and you'll only
be as emotional about it as you allow
yourself to be
uh-huh okay so here let me give you an
example okay let's try this let's put
the 1 million
270 000 in the middle of the kitchen
table
and um
if i burn 200 000 of it with a lighter
that be that would get you really riled
up
yeah
if i burn one dollar of it
you would go that's kind of dumb but
that was weird and it didn't bother you
a bit right
you know what i'm saying
and so my point is is this thing goes up
and down
it
it that's what that's the feeling you're
getting
and if you understand it's more it's
going up and down but it's not affecting
your life it's more like burning one
dollar of it
okay if you can have the emotions as it
goes up and down because it's really all
you're dealing with is your emotions
because the actual mathematical facts
will be that you're not going to run out
of this money
you're not going to outlive this money
not doing the stuff we're talking about
anyway
and not the way you've lived and not who
you are
and all of that i mean
if we just said you know you start at
what's rate of just spending it
without making any money on it at all
would it go i mean would you still have
money at 95 over 20 years divide that by
20 and you you you know you'd still be
okay and we're not even talking about
something that's stupid
so you're going to be just fine you are
an absolute
amazing
rock star
of financial planning
you're a multi-millionaire you're just
amazing
at 75 years old what was your position
with the government what did you do for
a living
i worked with insurance
what's that mean what did you do with
insurance were you the commissioner of
insurance
oh no
i was uh an examiner
okay examined insurance companies you
did insurance for the government yeah
she did exactly examine the companies
make sure they're doing what they're
supposed to be doing outstanding
regulatory
yeah and so you never made a huge pile
of money you just were really really
good at saving it
yeah
yeah
i don't want to be called cheap
but close
yeah but you you had a ringside seats to
knucklehead business leaders over the
years didn't you
oh some yeah
awesome i can't imagine
i can't imagine getting crossways with
sue she could pencil whip you oh my gosh
so you're great sit down with the
smartvestor pro
let them walk you through what some of
your options are and what they would
have looked like for the last 40 years
you get some historical data do one of
your examinations
that you're used to doing but this time
do it on mutual funds and get yourself a
comfort level where you understand what
you're doing don't do it because they
said do it don't do it because i said do
it
but um
i i think you're gonna be just fine if
you go with the standard four if you
want to calm it down a little bit flip
that aggressive off of there flip in a
balanced and that'll calm it down a
little more but you're gonna be just
fine there's no reason you need to be
dumb dumbing this money down you got all
kinds of margin all kinds of wiggle room
because of the way you've lived your
life you've lived like no one else and
now you can live and give like no one
else and i want you to find something to
go spend a hundred thousand dollars on
yeah go spend some of this
i want you i want you to i don't know
whether it's a trip around the world
after covid calms down or whatever i
don't know what it is but there's
something you've always wanted to do and
and i want you to get some joy
from this money that you've done such a
good job with
and i wouldn't hurt to have a little
generosity mix in i suspect you're
already a generous person though
wow that's powerful i was just saying
that's
that that's the reason we do this right
that's an everyday millionaire a baby
steps type millionaire she didn't do it
because we taught her it was not
technically a baby steps millionaire but
she started from nothing worked for the
government as an examiner in the
insurance department
50 years with no debt right and this is
where you end up
1.6 million plus her house incredible
this is the ramsey show
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
dr john dolone ramsey personality is my
co-host today
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt free stage daryl is with us hi
daryl how are you how you doing dave
better than i deserve man welcome where
do you live i'm from bloomington indiana
cool welcome to nashville and here to do
a debt-free scream how much do you pay
off i paid off 136 000 950. good for you
and how long did this take 56 months and
24 days good for you and your range of
income during that time 68 to 79.
cool what do you do for a living i'm an
engineer
work for a company called cook medical
medical device company very cool what
kind of debt was this 137 a little bit
of everything a cell phone couple credit
cards 401k loan personal loans a legal
bill and uh the biggest one was irs bill
also and a parent plus loan is the
biggest ah okay all right how much of
the 137 was parent plus uh 64 000. okay
so half of it yeah all right so
you had a little bit you had quite a
collection there you were pretty normal
very normal yes yeah all right and uh so
what happened five years ago that blew
this normal up well i became single and
that kind of shook me up a little bit
there's the legal bill yeah so i got uh
exactly i uh
had that before and then after i became
single i had him own dead on to that too
so that kind of accumulated
and i started listening to your show i
remember correctly
probably in the spring of 2018
and went to an feu class in the fall of
2018
and then i started dialing into budget
and all that kind of stuff
so in classic engineer fashion you go
there's got to be a formula and i don't
know what i've got to go find the
formula exactly yes yep follow the
process yep yeah engineers number one
career category of the millionaires that
we study yeah uh they follow processes
and this process is pretty clean and
pretty simple to understand but just
getting the human beings to actually do
a clean and simple thing is the trick
and you did it congratulations thank you
thank you very very very well done
all right so you're going to the
financial peace university class and
here we stand five years later
voila not really but i mean that's a
long run right it was a it was a grind
yeah it was how did you stay with it
well being an engineer i'm very
consistent um i'm pretty self-motivated
but it was tough it was a grind i had my
kids that are riding me cheering me on
and helped me out
um but you were grinding and healing at
the same time too that's doubly hard
right yeah yeah it was tough yep yeah
what kept you going
my faith for sure my faith uh that was a
big part of it
and um just praying
being with my kids when i could so it
was tough but i grind yeah but it was
worth it
i've never been debt free since i
got out of college and started working
back in 1985. wow and now you're free
yeah
wow yep working on my debts looking on
babysit three it should have had that
done in march yeah yeah how does it feel
to be free feels great
uh you got a whole bunch of crap in your
rear view mirror don't you i do i do
yeah it really feels nice to finally put
money you know in the bank for myself
going forward yeah yeah amen
okay so you're a financial peace
university graduate an engineer that
understands processes you pay off 137
000
in five years basically a little less
than five years what do you tell people
the key is to getting out of debt it's
definitely the budget
it's definitely the budget i used to
track my expenses but that's different
than budgeting so a lot of time you
track your expenses and heads into money
like wow i where'd all my money go um
but i didn't really have a plan and i
didn't budget
and when i first started budgeting when
i went through the fbu class
um i think you said
how many times about when you do a
budget and rachel says it's too that you
it's like you get a raise and it was
like wow i got extra money here once i
paid attention to where things were
going and i used if i make it behave
before it leaves instead of looking at
it after it leaves exactly yeah tracking
the expenses is too late right yeah
you've got you've got to make it behave
before it leaves and that's make it make
it do what it's supposed to do work
towards the goal and crack the whip on
it
yeah
yeah good for you so the budget anything
else
well you got to be consistent
um and of course the process works
the baby steps work the plan works um
and being an engineer i love processes
so it was pretty
easy i wouldn't say easy for me but as
far as staying on track um although it
was
simple but not easy right exactly yeah
can i ask you a hard question sure you
can just say hey i don't answer that
question um one of the one of the
biggest challenges of somebody in your
situation is
you can be grinding on something
and look around and it's pretty lonely
who walked alongside you in this process
god for sure um one of the things i do
every morning is i read three chapters
out of the bible which you can get
through the bible in one year if you do
that and i'm on my 10th year by the way
of doing that so wow happy that so
that's a big part of it my kids i have
some very close friends that helped me
get through it fantastic uh one of my
the ministers at my church i talked to
him a lot about it that's fantastic
kudos to you for for understanding i got
to have people walk alongside me
too many men bury their head in that
deal and you did and i'm proud of you
man yeah especially last couple of years
with covenant all that yeah it's hard i
didn't go anywhere basically i would go
to work come home and
um
i went through and got my mba during
that time for any last couple of years
but why not can't listen why not right
yeah
well you're a hero man
you're incredible i'm proud of you thank
you thank you very very well done i'm
sure your kids are proud of you they are
and they're all debt free and they're
walking the plants too so i love it i
love it and they all came with you to
cheer you on here yeah yeah all right
and so uh how old are they we're not
going to pull them up because they're
not kids they're grown-ups but uh
how old are they
i'm sorry go ahead go ahead how old are
the names samantha's uh 28 she's the
oldest my son james the bearded wonder
he's uh
25 and my youngest son jonathan is 21
and he's currently in school at purdue
as an engineer ah okay and you you get
the legacy change here right yeah
they're fantastic kids they're all oh no
you well yeah you put in the work five
years they got to watch your old man
grind and grind and grind and they're
gonna live a different life because the
work you did man yeah yeah my daughter
just told me this morning that she paid
off her debt her student loan debt
yesterday wow yeah yeah love it love it
love it this is the way it's supposed to
be very cool man well done daryl thank
you very well done we've got a copy of
the brand new book baby steps
millionaires for you you will be one
very very soon if you're not already
and you're on your way get that house
paid off next and keep filling up the
401k it is as he said five times a
process it's a process yeah i love it
and also a copy total money makeover for
you to give away and disturb someone
with that's our goal to create a holy
ruckus out there man so hey thank you
thank you thank you well thank you and
thank you dr john
so proud of you all right daryl from
indiana 137
000 paid off in 56 months making 68 to
79 count it down let's hear a debt free
scream
three two one i'm debt free
[Applause]
so the interesting thing about this is
we discovered
early on at ramsey that personal finance
is 80 behavior
it's only 20 of knowledge that's why the
work that you do
uh works so well with the work that we
were already doing here it's a natural
overlay a natural discussion that we
always have here
and having said that
you know daryl just reminded us several
times
that this is math just follow the plan
if you just do the math the bridge will
not fall down just follow the plan if
you're an engineer
you know if you just do the math you
will get the result and it is it is it
is math and math is not racist and math
is not sexist and math does not have
ptsd
it's math and math works in california
believe it or not
and math works in tennessee and math
works in texas
it's math yeah so do
the freaking
math do the behaviors that cause the
math to occur that's the process for the
process and when you do that you not
only get out of debt but you put
yourself in a position that you've
changed your family tree and oh by the
way you've got three beautiful grown
children watching you
hero
watching you watching your character
watching the kind of man you are and you
are forming
their adult patterns as their young
adults and that will form their kids and
their you are changing your family tree
exactly
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
dr john baloney ramsey personality is my
co-host today here on the ramsey show
liz is with us in chicago hi liz how are
you
hi dave i'm good how are you better than
i deserve what's up
okay so i am on baby step two
and
um i'm listening to currently the um
baby step millionaires
and
i guess i have been focusing on baby
step two for so long but i never really
focused on four through seven and in it
fifteen percent of your income should be
going towards retirement
um and i was just doing the math and
fifteen percent of my income now is
going towards baby step two so i can't
wrap my head around
how i'll have extra when i start
investing for college and paying off the
mortgage
well you're not gonna you may not have a
lot extra
what's your income okay
um combined 75 000.
okay how much is your house payment
759.
how much
17.59 okay
including our
escrow and everything yeah yeah okay all
right
uh i think you're gonna be okay
yeah i think you're gonna be okay i mean
you you're on the budget you just gave
me you should be able to
we're talking about investing about ten
thousand dollars a year about eight
hundred bucks a month
and on seventy five thousand dollars a
year without any payments but a 1700
house payment i think you can do that
i feel like we're just really tight well
you're not supposed to be doing it right
now you have to get rid of the debt
no i know i know i'm just kind of
thinking ahead and you just started i'm
the nurse
i know well unfortunately that starts
had a lot i've actually spoke with you
before we had um we had a lot of lot a
lot of debt going into baby step two so
i have i'm like
83 of the way done yeah i think you need
to worry about baby step four when you
get there
okay let's just worry about getting out
of debt right now
okay you're super you're super nerding
yourself into worrying yes i am
worrying about something that's not
happened yet
yeah you're gonna be okay that's what i
do all the time i know you're gonna be
okay okay live for today live in this
now say live for today you're gonna plan
ahead but be present in this moment
right here emotionally
you have paid off a big pile of debt
already yes you're going to finish that
you're going to breathe deeper than you
breathe right now nothing standing on
your lungs anymore
and you'll be able to
and it's just so when you get to baby
step four it's a different your body
feels different so let's let's unpack
that she's been terrified her body has
been on red alert knowing they are not
safe well you borrow her slave to the
lender exactly right and and this was a
nasty butt master and so now she's
realizing oh we're about to get close
and her brain goes to search for the
next problem to solve and to defend from
and when you get this thing paid off you
go
oh okay and then your brain can realize
we're safe your body
and then we've got an emergency fund of
three to six months of expenses we're
really safe and then the big bad wolf
comes outside your brick house that's
right and you go
oh little puppy what's your problem well
you're not running for your life you may
look in the mirror and say i think i
want to make more than 35 grand a year
honestly i'm gonna huff and i'm gonna
puff and you're gonna do what i'm gonna
break it out shut up let me get another
job or whatever so yeah get through with
this process first yeah you're gonna be
okay you're gonna be just fine as a
matter of fact you you really are
because of the way you've described the
situation and john talks about this a
lot with stress and anxiety and other
things you and your case are really
going to physically feel different yes
now different people do different things
but you can there's a i don't know a
tightness across your back or whatever
it is and i i've experienced it and when
it's gone it feels like a 300 pound
you know monkey got off your back i
descend on that draft on monday i'm just
i'm feeling it over the course this week
come off right and i know what's
happening and yeah sheila passed me on
the back and says i was just still
coming off like yeah it'll it'll get
there okay yeah okay we're done now
we're done all right it's okay it's okay
no tigers no tigers no tigers calm down
calm down it's okay
no tiger going to eat you yeah that's
that with your body it does that i mean
you get amped up man you stay in this
constant amped up i'm gonna kill
something you move to the next thing to
worry about that's the gazelle intensity
and i told you to do that right you know
it's important it's the best way to get
out of the thing is to run for your
freaking life but then when you get the
other side you take a breath and you go
from intense to intentional
and that's a different place to be brian
is with us in chattanooga hey brian
what's up
hey dave how's it going better than i
deserve how can i help
all right i got some questions about uh
giving
um we're currently on baby set four five
and six good and we're but we're
budgeting what we give to the church
have been for a while now good and
situations came up where
we have an opportunity to give outside
of the church
and i'm wondering should i
take that money away from the church
that i had budgeted or how am i supposed
to work this together
you know not just for this situation
from here on out
how much we talking does that make sense
um it's like 500 600
okay
my uh my buddy got kicked out of the
house and um i'm trying to get him a
hotel i got him a job and i'm i'm really
just trying to help him just show him
love yeah i suspect you got 500
yeah
all right i i do okay then give him 500
okay this ain't rocket science man
yeah i just didn't know about like
budgeting if you want to if you want to
talk philosophically and step back and
go tactically i want to be prepared for
this ongoing i'll answer your other
question but in this guy's case just
just give him before you got the money
you shut them do it now the uh uh
we budget sharon and i do
in our family foundation and in our
personal budget for a certain amount of
pocket money
just when we see something and god says
that's yours to take care of i just put
you here for this
and you just kind of have that feeling
run down the back of your neck and you
go yeah that lady i'm supposed to do
that right there i'm supposed to buy
that those groceries and you just do it
and you don't think anything about it
because you got an extra little bit of
pocket money so i carry a little bit of
extra just slush money for that just
because it's stinking fun
you know we actually budgeted my fund
money
in my spend money in my house me my wife
i i put it in she puts it in the you can
go buy something with it or you can pick
up somebody's groceries yeah and we just
do stuff i mean that way you're just in
a position to do that and we we put
another zero on it we keep a little
extra over in the family foundation
budget to do some stuff like that as
well but in your case the other question
is you know give to the church uh i'm an
evangelical that believes in tithing i
give a tenth of my income to my local
church and i don't that's really not
part of this equation that's just a
baseline
i do that and then everything else i do
in addition to that and uh so you know
you would have for instance a
spontaneous giving line in your budget
and you would have your tithe line in
your budget if you were doing it the way
i do and that's fine if you're not a
tither and you don't believe in tithing
to your local church then that's the
thing but the way you said i give to my
church i'm anticipating that that's what
you were doing or that's the type of
thing you were doing but no i wouldn't
take it out of i don't take it out of my
tithe i don't go well i gave some money
to this single mom we bought our car and
so we don't have to put it in the tithe
no i don't do that that's the church if
the church can do that with the money i
tithed if they want but but uh if we're
gonna do it over here that's separate
i've got this baseline rhythm
in my life this groove in my in behavior
pattern that's consistent that just it
baselines the generosity and then from
there there's you know
other kinds of generosity that shoots
out of that but we don't i don't dip
down into that to keep from having to do
others that make sense oh that's
absolutely and you said it man when you
if you keep a little extra money in your
wallet i don't there's not a lot of
things more fun
than just grabbing somebody's gas at a
gas station or i mean it's just out of
the blue
and you just watch people's eyes what
get wide i don't know that uh that makes
me feel good man
it's one of my favorite things to do
it's it's about the most fun you'll ever
have money i mean like go you know go
bananas on a tip or something like make
the tip six times the bill or something
just to just to be messing with somebody
just because you had a feeling that that
needed to be done right there right yeah
you know and i pay attention to those
feelings i like that that's why you know
uh
you know we're it's not our money we're
managing it for god yeah and i think he
smiles a lot when we do stuff like that
so uh that's awesome and uh so do the
rest of us so it's fun
it's fun so you're a good man you're
good man brian thanks for taking care of
your buddy give him 500 bucks dude yeah
like in the next 20 minutes right now
yeah thanks for the call that puts this
hour of the ramsey show in the books
thanks to john deloney to ben and to
kelly and to james in the booth i am
dave ramsey your host and we will be
back
[Music]
hey it's kelly associate producer and
phone screener for the ramsay show if
you would like to do your debt free
scream live on the show make sure you
visit
and register we would love for you to
come to nashville and tell dave your
story
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career
you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsay show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
i'm dave ramsey your host dr john
deloney ramsey personality best-selling
author and host of the dr john baloney
show is my co-host today
uh you can join us here on the ramsay
show as we talk about your relationships
your work your money and you
it's a free call at triple eight eight
two five
five two two five this is launch week
for our new book called baby steps
millionaires and a bazillion of you have
bought the book thank you so much
we appreciate it this is a uh become
quite a little hot seller thank you man
it's gone bonkers how ordinary people
built extraordinary wealth and how you
can too
now we launched this book in the middle
of a society where a
portion of the people are out there
i call them hope stealers
their job is to steal your hope their
job is to tell you that the society the
culture of the country that we live in
is so broken that the little man can't
get ahead
you stand no chance unless you inherit
it from a rich uncle you can't make it
we need socialism
we need wealth redistribution
wealthy people are evil anyway correct
and so they should be punished
continue and um you know i mean that
then these hope stealers are everywhere
and uh james our producer handed me a
sheet a minute ago this is so
interesting uh farhad
manjo i guess that's how it's pronounced
i may have messed up your name there sir
i apologize
has a whole section in the new york
times on abolishing millionaires
a billion dollars is wildly more than
anyone needs
even accounting for life's most
excessive lavishes
it's far more than anyone might
reasonably claim to deserve
however much he believes he has
contributed to society billionaires
should not exist
when american capitalism sends us its
billionaires it's sending not sending us
its best it's sending us people who have
lots of problems and they're bringing
problems with them they're bringing
inequality
this from a guy who is a reporter
with student loan debt from his
journalism degree but
uh this is you know this is the ultimate
tall poppy syndrome the poppy sticks up
his head above the others it must be cut
down
and so we're supposed to be
jealous and
envious to evil ideas to carry evil
character traits of anyone who is one
with money evil money is evil
money is bad if you get money you are
evil and you are bad and you should have
it taken away from you and given to
someone else so that they are evil and
bad i guess i never thought about that
part yeah but um if we give it out is it
not a problem to the poor people that
get it i mean if it's bad maybe we
should just centralize it with a few
people and destroy them instead of
giving it to other people that's kind of
illogical the critical thinking breaks
down on this doesn't it
mr buffett is actually the most
dangerous kind of billionaire we have
this guy says
the worst billionaires are good
billionaires the sort who make it seem
like the problem is the distortion of
the system when in fact the problem is
the system
there should be no way that anyone has a
million or billion dollars in america
these are the voices that are out there
um now i'm old when i was young we call
those communists
what's that
who didn't want people who act this way
that say these kinds of things this is
straight up marxism
i mean it's uh but this idea and of
course aoc's policy advisor dan ripple
comes out and contends that every
billionaire we have is because there's a
policy failure
the acquisition of that much wealth has
bad consequences and a moral society
needs guard rails against it
see that's straight up marxism
so let's take so i'm just thinking of
the first guy that popped into my head
um
everybody's favorite target elon musk
comes up with
a cool computer program and sells it for
a lot of money
helps a lot of people do a lot of things
then he develops
a car and a battery
but here's the thing what's the inherent
evil there i'm perplexed by the argument
well it it is not and it's not logical
it's not good critical thinking skills
marxism never is so what ends up
happening is that that the whole thing
is about vilifying
wealth and the wealthy okay so that we
can do a power grab
and move the money around and get credit
for it
it's a power grab thing
um and it that's generally what is at
the core of marxism or these kinds of
things all along so
here's what actually happens though in
the real world okay not in these
people's little fairy tale minds that
they have
in the real world the most generous
people on the planet are the wealthy
no really this is actual data
not theory not political rhetoric that's
trying to beat a drum but the actual
data says
that wealthy people feed more starving
children than not wealthy people do
80
gave to a charity in 2020. 88 of
affluent households donated in 2020
in a year with a global pandemic and
other crisis where people were scared to
death
there was a record of philanthropy nine
out of ten
nine out of ten households the study of
a survey of 1626 households with a net
worth of one million dollars or more
millionaires
there they are again excluding the value
of their primary residence which means
they're worth more than a million
considerably
annual household income of 200 000
these are the people studied of them
they gave 88 of them donated to charity
yeah and and i got to tell you that
everything we get our hands on about it
says that they not only donate to
charity they consistently donate to
charity and it is substantial yeah
um
but yet they are
by marxist journalism student at the new
york times are evil
evil rich people and and everyone knows
that a camel can't go get through the
eye of the needle so
we know that rich people aren't going to
heaven right according to atheists who
misquote scripture and don't understand
it on twitter
right i don't know i know some believers
that quote that too but yeah i know yeah
but they're they're ignorant of the
they need to work on their bible study
skills and so because it's a problem
because here's the thing that is
actually when you take that stance as a
christian that's actually gnosticism
which is a first century form of heresy
let me walk you through this okay
if
rich people can't get to heaven if
that's your conclusion of that scripture
because you didn't read it in context
and you didn't finish reading jesus's
words afterwards which if you do it
explains it away and you understand
what's going on but if rich people can't
get to heaven
that means that the work that jesus did
on the cross and shed his blood is not
strong enough to cover rich people
there's an exemption there that's called
heresy uh
in doctrinal studies yeah okay that is a
type of heresy and it's called
gnosticism guys and so you know this
you little socialists who go rich people
can't get into heaven you're actually
heretics
i don't the idea that you dismiss
somebody out of hand their character who
they are how
based on their net worth
seems like the the
a loaf
it seems like the lowest form of
critical insight kind of feels like
there's an agenda it's just
so reductive and dismissive i might join
rachel cruz in a conspiracy theory
nope she's in a league of her own david
oh she is in a league of her own for
sure this is the ramsay show
[Music]
so
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free
shipping with blinds.com there's no need
to renovate your entire home just change
out what's on your windows with upscale
choices like faux wood blinds cellular
and roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
so
[Music]
thank you for joining us america this is
the ramsey show we're so glad you're
here
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five it's launch week
for the new book baby steps millionaires
thank you to all of you who have
purchased it we appreciate that you can
get it anywhere great books are sold
it's in
target and sam's it's in barnes and
noble it's everywhere
certainly ramsey solutions.com as well
and uh if you want to join in on this
whole wealth building movement and
become one of those evil rich people we
were talking about we want to show you
how and we're going to do that tonight
rachel cruz george camel and i will be
doing a live event here in just a few
hours
seven o'clock central time
here in nashville we've got about 1 600
folks in the sold out event space itself
in addition to that we will of course
have it streaming live online for those
of you that want to do that and it's
completely free online
and so we would love to have you join us
just go to ramseysolutions.com
wealth put in your email and you can
join the online streaming for free if
you don't like the event we'll give you
half your money back so check it out
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five you jump in john
delony and i will help you out victor's
in san jose hi victor welcome to the
ramsay show
dave good afternoon how are you better
than i deserve what's up
dave i've uh i wish i i got on your
plane a few years ago i'm a new listener
and
the plan that i've had for myself is
very muddy and cloudy and so um
and so i like your plan and i hope i'm
getting i'm gonna get some insight here
uh hey talking directly to your phone
brother hey you're muffled like crazy
you need to speak directly right
there there you go sorry there you go um
totally
is that better yeah sure right
so we we make quite a bit of money over
300 000 a year
and with uh tax deductions and all sorts
of benefits that we pay for out of that
and saving for retirement
we take home roughly 200 000
and
so then i i started doing a whole lot of
things and maybe i took on too much so
the fundamentals here i have about 80
000 in savings
i have 200 000 in a 401k
i have 30 000 in a raw
42 000 in an index fund right
and
um i've got a house mortgage for 365 000
which i don't listen to
a second i apologize but we can't do
your whole financial plan what's your
question
oh um
so
my main question was i took on two
rentals that i have
i have a mortgage on
and the idea was that i would keep these
for 15 years and they would pay for my
kids college
cool fund good
and
i've got a mortgage on them they cash
flow positive to pay that mortgage but
i'm not sure if that's a great idea yet
and i've got these index fund uh forty
two thousand dollars sitting there that
i also was going to use as a liquid
fund for kids college or uh whatever is
needed 15 years down the line okay i'm
going to back you all the way up and pan
out to
clarify you said you've got this
murkiness because there's too many
things going into me directions so let's
just streamline it right down the baby
steps so make sure you have an emergency
fund of three to six months of expenses
setting liquid
in a simple savings account don't touch
that for anything that's just for
emergencies make sure you're debt-free
but your house i think you are based on
what you're saying you're making really
good money
then at baby step four you need to be
putting 15 percent of your household
income into retirement
you're putting some of your money into
retirement you talked about the
difference in your 300 down to 200 so i
don't know exactly what that number is
but go back and recalculate and make
sure you are putting 15 of your income
into retirement baby step five is kids
college six is pay off your home as
quickly as you can
and so you've got some rentals that
you're thinking you might use for the
kids college you might do some other
things so i'm taking the 42 out of the
index fund i'm taking some of the money
out of the 80 000 sitting in savings
i'm gonna set some aside for that three
to six months of expenses i'm gonna
throw the rest of it at your personal
mortgage when your mortgage is gone then
we'll reach over and start paying off
those rentals
and so let's get the mortgage knocked
out and then start paying off the
rentals as fast as you can and just
direct your cash flow at those things
instead of instead of dispersing it
across so many different things because
what you're realizing is is that
by spreading out the focus by not having
any focus the money loses its power
when you focus it and narrow it down and
rifle it rather than shotgun it it'll go
a lot further a lot faster
much like a rifle versus a shotgun does
and so that that's what you've got to do
here and that's the beauty and the
clarity of these baby steps and walking
them that way hang on man i will send
you a copy of the new book baby steps
millionaires it'll talk about what i'm
talking about here and exactly how to do
it to turn what you're doing into
millionaire status but the clarity is
what you're missing you're all over the
place with it and you're right you you
self-diagnose that really well yeah so
and man you'll sleep better yeah you'll
just sleep better you live in that
chaotic life everything's everywhere
you'll just have a more peaceful life
and when there's a circus going on in
your brain it's hard to sleep i mean
it's just it's that's normal
adam's with us in orange county hi adam
welcome to the ramsay show
thanks dave thanks for taking my call
sure uh i had a quick question for you
um we're we're following your program
we've been saving for the last five
years to buy a house we put a big down
payment on we got into a house
and my company just got recently
acquired by a private equity firm and
i've been gifted some shares to the
company
but then i also have an opportunity to
be a co-investor into the company
and my
kind of decision
yeah yeah
i don't i don't want to be a minor
stockholder with a private equity firm
being the dog
i'll pass
you got no control you have no reporting
you have no liquidity
you you're gonna get your you know
you've got as good a chance of getting
your head taken off as you do making
money here it's a very very high risk
play
very high risk play i wouldn't do it
i mean
and i get the opportunity to do stuff
like that every day and i don't do it
and i've got the ability to lose the
money and still be okay and i don't do
it um it's just a it's an uber high-risk
play now if i were the private equity
firm and i could control everything then
i might do it but the fact you got no
control you're sitting in a minority
stockholder position
they can just vote
crap going on there that you don't want
anything to do with and they run the
company poorly they run in the ditch
they can sell it off for pennies on the
dollar because they lose patience with
the deal and you go with them on the
ride and you don't get any choice
so now
it's like getting in the back seat when
you're a freshman and
your brother's a senior and all his
friends are too and you're going
wherever they're going to go well and
they've been drinking healthy and
they've been drinking too that's right
that's exactly there's that yeah
max is in new york hey max welcome to
the ramsey show
hey thanks taking my call sure man
what's up
so i am 23 years old i
have about 70 thousand dollars in
student debt 71 000.
i
made a routine investment into nfts
uh lost about fifteen thousand dollars
well let me stop you right there you
can't lose money on nfts their foolproof
way to become a billionaire right
i thought everybody made money on
bitcoin and nfts what happened nfts are
the future banks
yeah you'd think so you would think so
if you read reddit you lost 15k
15k and you're 23 years old with seventy
thousand dollars in credit cards gosh
how quickly did that go away man like
twenty seconds um
probably about a month and it's not
credit card debt seventy one thousand
student loans i know i said did i say
credit card i'm sorry you did say
student loans i i heard you but i just
messed up i'm sorry i'm poking at you
but i'm sorry that's a yeah we just we
get trashed all the time for telling
people not to do this and then here
calls a guy 23 years old this is why we
tell people not to do it just exactly
what happened to you so you put 15 000
real money into this where'd you get
fifteen thousand dollars
i make 90k a year good
okay so let me just tell you i think
this is absolutely wonderful the best
thing that ever happened to you
you're not 83 you're 23 and you already
got one level of stupid out of the way
you'll never do this again will you
man you just paid 15 grand in stupid tax
that you will never pay again that when
you are alive same thing when i was your
age max i lost five grand in 26 minutes
on a gold future
this guy was never he hit everything on
gold futures i put money on goldfish it
just evaporated i had to go home and
tell my wife and she looked at me like
the idiot that i was i was 24 years old
23 15 grand you know what i have never
lost another dime on the future either
by god
you get it out of the way when you're 23
it's awesome man you make 90 000. you're
a stud get on with your life you're
great never do it again
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
dr john dolone ramsey personality is my
co-host today
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five thank you for
joining us in the lobby of ramsey
solutions
with a question joey from chicago hi
joey how are you good how you doing dave
and john better than we deserve brother
what's up so i had a question uh for
retirement advice um
i'm in the uh i'm blessed to be part of
a uh trade union and i'm an electrician
in chicago and uh so i've got the uh
pension and annuity through that and so
as far as my take-home pay that
part that's withheld for retirement
equals around 30 percent
so i was wondering as far as like maybe
additional investing because you usually
say kind of don't count that to the
fullest when you don't have full control
i saw some things um i kind of got the
eye for real estate like you do and uh i
saw some things where you can have
a portion of
real estate
kind of like a mutual fund works where
it's uh
you
you invest in uh
the company you invest with gets you uh
portions of real estate and kind of
uh invest that way well there are
several models of that the the most
liquid and the most i mean you can get
your money back out and the most uh
stable and reputable version would be a
reit a real estate investment trust an
reit
and that is basically a mutual fund for
real estate and the better run reits
have gotten as good of returns as like a
growth stock mutual fund would so
they're doing really well overall and if
you want to get in that way that's not a
bad place to play given the way you've
got the rest of your portfolio is out of
your control but it's over there
hopefully in mutual funds with the union
and everything and in those annuities
and all that stuff so um yeah that
wouldn't be a bad way to do it now
there's other ways that you can buy
portions
into things some limited partnership
stuff and some other things
those would probably scare me in your
situation
so i if i were in your shoes i probably
would do one of two things i would
either buy reits
um
or i would buy reits until i had enough
money in that that i could cash it out
and just buy me a piece of real estate
that's kind of what i was thinking yeah
that kind of a thing i might do that and
just call it all real estate as far as a
category goes that's not a bad idea at
all actually it's a good way to get to
the business and have your money in the
real estate business but
the reits early on 20 years ago 25 years
ago they were they had a lot of heavy
fees and they were
milking the properties with management
fees before the money got to the
investor and so the returns weren't that
great but uh in the last probably decade
or so they've really become a valid
uh
good long track record well-run
you can research them like you research
a mutual fund you could get with a smart
vista pro and pick one out even that
kind of a thing but yeah i think that
would not be a bad idea at all that's a
good that's a good idea i would not do
limited partnerships i wouldn't do
partial things um you know where you
like a hundred people are coming
together and doing a deal i wouldn't do
that that's
that's more like that last guy that he's
got a
minority interest in us in a company
that kind of thing you get yourself in a
pinch there but the reits are more
mutual fund-ish
like in terms of how they operate and or
then just pay cash for some real estate
yourself that's cool i like that idea
yeah me too hey thanks for stopping by
brother thanks
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five gabriel is in
bozeman montana hi gabriel how are you
i'm good how are you better than i
deserve what's up
uh so i'm i'm wondering if i should move
to texas so
the situation is that i am having
difficulty fun a good job uh where i
live right now
um
and currently i'm doing doordash uh to
to pay for everything
the thing that complicates that
is that i recently got
rear-ended
um and the tow hitch of my car is broken
do you have a job lined up in texas
i i do not um why texas
yeah what's going to be different about
texas than than
montana
so um
in montana uh well it's really too cold
i guess um
i also have difficulty finding
apartments um
so
in the entire state there's like 10
apartments available right um
and gabriel
come on
i want to move somewhere that i play if
you want to move that's fine but you
don't have to lie about montana there's
10 apartments in montana montana come on
dude really i mean you just said that
out loud in front of everybody
seriously okay so if you want to move to
texas i'm cool with that fix your
trailer hitch and load it up load up the
truck and head to beverly man
all right
what's the hesitation why not just go
fix your share of the hitch and go
what are we missing
um
so
i'm
i need to like uh gather a uh moving
funds
um
the the hesitation there is that um i
have been considering for a couple of
months and i'm not i feel like i'm not
quite ready to pull the trigger just yet
i mean like you said i don't have a job
lined up i need to i need to make sure
that i
have that first if i am doing that how
old are you
i'm 19
19. okay where do your where's your
family live
uh my family lives in here in the state
of montana okay
all right
could you swing by there and camp for a
little while and build up some money and
get some family support before you head
out
all right
go ahead um i think
so
i think that's off the table right now
um i've already
um lived under their roof for a little
bit and they i'm pretty sure they made
it clear that like
um you're you're on your own now um
i am currently living under a friend
guest bedroom for
uh for rents which is around 300 bucks a
month
so it sounds gabriel it sounds like what
you need brother it sounds like you got
a lot of
apprehension and a lot of things in your
head and a lot of things floating around
and a lot of uncertainty
man i really want you to get a buddy and
y'all go out and grab some chips and
queso
and
make a plan write this stuff down on a
piece of paper
and it's gonna get it out of your head
and get it from all over the place man
because you you've got some a lot of
fear built up do you have some mental
health challenges you struggle with
i'm sorry can you please repeat that do
you have some mental health challenges
that you struggle with
uh no
no i i um
i am struggling to make money though um
i'm making around anywhere between a
thousand and fifteen fifteen hundred
bucks a month and i feel like i'm not
able to pay off my debt with that amount
of money absolutely yes i don't disagree
with that
um but there's a whole lot of uh
bouncing around going on in our
conversation with you yeah and so what
we're trying to help you do is to settle
down and streamline through a game plan
here
texas feels like it was just going to be
the land the glory land where everything
was going to be okay and everything was
going to be different the common
denominator is it'd still be you yeah
you go with you
brother and so you gotta you gotta work
on all that so
uh have you have you been a member of a
good church
um i have not no okay
uh do you have um
some of your dad's older friends that
you trust
to kind of coach you
since the whole thing with your parents
is not going that great
um
not really
okay
um so i'd love to get somebody in your
life that has their crap together
that would sit down with you and kind of
walk you through over some chips in
queso maybe more so than one of your
buddies that might kind of give you a
little bit of coaching a little bit of
guidance and tell you and love what they
see
and what you can do to get this stuff
going
because i i i
i don't think you are um
running to something in texas i think
you're running from something and i
don't think you're going to find it
there you absolutely will not yeah
you ask brother and we're obligated to
tell you because we love you
this is the ramsey show
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture of the day is proverbs 10
4 lazy hands make for poverty but
diligent hands bring wealth
ralph waldo emerson said the best
lightning rod for your protection is
your own spine oh i've never heard that
wow
the best lightning rod for your
protection is your own spine
boom
love it love it love it hey blinds.com
gives us our question of the day
they have a 100 satisfaction guarantee
that means even if you mismeasure you
pick the wrong color they'll remake your
window blinds for free with free samples
free shipping new promos all the time
it's a great american company the place
to get your window blinds for sure
blinds.com use the promo code ramsey to
get the best deal today's question comes
from sarah in canada my husband and i
earn about five thousand dollars a month
and we're 30 000 in debt we've been
looking for a new rental situation which
is challenging in the current market out
of the blue one of my husband's clients
offered to let us live in one of our
homes for 500 bucks a month my husband
will still get paid normally when doing
work for her she is a real rags to rich
historian is incredibly generous and for
the first time we don't have to be
scared about whether we can make rent or
bills and our debt will be paid off
quickly my question is this when you've
always been treading water to keep your
head just barely above it how do you
learn to kick back and float
how do you let yourself feel safe and
breathe for the first time in years
[Music]
there's a lot in this question dave
here's my thoughts off top of my head
there is a difference between letting
yourself feel safe and breathing and
kicking back and floating ah great and
if you kick back and float you will
never feel safe and you will never be
able to breathe
and so i don't want you to ever quote
unquote kick back and float um the i
wish there was a sexier way to say this
but you got to practice you got to
practice reminding yourself you and your
husband come up with new words that you
give for each other when the other
person's starting to get amped up and
you say hey let's take a breath my wife
and i did this for years anybody healing
from trauma does this you practice it
and you call it out with each other and
over time your body adjusts to being
safe and i'll also tell you if you're
living in a special rent situation
you're not safe
you got to save up some money and get
yourself your own place because this
isn't going to be this way forever
that's my thoughts so when
we're coaching people
with their money
and they're in a highly stressed out
freaked out they're behind on their
bills their car is about to be repo'ed
they got a lot of debt
it is
it if the first
10 years i did it it caught me off guard
it would catch me off guard it no longer
does just because of experience
that when people start doing a budget
and then they use the money that they've
got and they say we've got this much
money and on this date we'll have that
fixed on that date we'll have that fixed
on that date we'll have that debt paid
off on that date we'll be debt free on
that day we'll have our emergency fund
based on projecting the budget that's in
front of me and they do their budget for
the first time and they're able to
extrapolate their future
none of the work is done
their situation has not changed
only their
ability to see their way out of their
situation with a system
has changed
that is where you can breathe and feel
safe and their stress level goes down 90
just by laying out the freaking plan
there's some research that says people
with the moment you make your first
counseling appointment you start to feel
better well and people cancel their
counseling appointment because they feel
better yeah they feel better like they
they
have a big fight book a marriage
counseling appointment and then they
make up then they don't get the help
they need and then they don't get the
help then they cancel the appointment
happens all the time the same thing
happens when you do a budget even though
you still have your bills are out there
screwed up everything's still up in the
air it's still a mess
but now you can see how you're going to
get out the stress level drops 90
percent and that's when you can breathe
and feel safe so you need to project
this
temporary rent situation that you have
out
and say we're going to be out of debt
here and we're going to move out of this
voluntarily before the generosity of the
runs out sweet lady runs out and she you
change your narrative about the way you
look at her because suddenly she
actually wants to collect rent
and so um and all that's different than
kicking back and floating yeah doing you
feel safe because of your plan you
breathe because of your plan because you
can we we have a thing we're doing here
we're working the baby steps we're on a
budget we can see the progress we can
see a future that is bright
there's a vision for our life and your
stress level goes down and you breathe
and feel safe but you're not kicking
back and floating you're you're busting
it with great intensity that's right
so yeah i agree with you to separate
those two statements and
i i think you're wanting
something you should probably never get
which is to do nothing don't ever
don't ever want to strive to do nothing
yeah resting is not nothing there's no
joy in it there's no joy
you gotta rest and rest isn't that's not
what we're saying and you gotta sleep
it's not what we're saying those are
critical parts to being well but you got
to be intentional about rest you got to
be intentional about sleep you feel safe
and breathe while you're getting crap
done absolutely that's that's how you
feel safe is having purpose and working
towards something that's a good point
that's a good point there's a there's
this empty nothingness
thing i mean you these uh chambers that
they've got at these things now where
you can go float oh yeah and all this
stuff yeah i'd say that that is not i
mean it's fine to do and i'm not mad at
her it's nothing like that it's not a
way of life but you don't want your life
to be that oh you want your life to be
i'm climbing a mountain and me and my
wife is i'm going on a hike me and pat
lincoln are talking about that our whole
culture's set up for that
to the goal we work to do nothing to do
nothing to get to the end of the day and
sit in your recliner and kick it back so
you can do nothing no what is lame which
is why people die right after they
retire
or they die all the way their working
life
that's even worse
josh is in chicago hey josh how are you
hey guys how are you doing today great
man what's up
i just had a quick career question
that i've been i've been struggling with
it's a little bit of background
three years ago
because of a retinal disease that i was
diagnosed with when i was a baby uh
started kind of going crazy on me and uh
since then i've been losing vision
and at this point i'm
blind for lack of a better diagnosis
my problem is is i i've been looking for
work
and
i'm struggling to find a company or a
specific job role
that is uh enables me to use computers
and programs with a screen reader
technology that blind users use
so i guess i'm just wondering is
do i think about making a
career path change what are you doing
what's your career
so uh before all this happened i was uh
i worked at a small small business i was
a marketing and sales manager on top of
doing customer service i wore a lot of
hats there um so what would you do what
would you do
if you could do anything using this
computer program to aid you in doing the
thing
what would you do
i've been asked this a couple times
since
since like the beginning of the year and
i keep falling back on something
customer service related i just i love
working with people i love trying to
understand where they're coming from
um
and you know that's that's where i feel
like i would succeed the most especially
you know having a disability i would
want to set myself up to grow within a
role in an industry
and um
that's that's kind of that's where i'm
at i can't i can't really think of
of anything else i would love to do in
addition to continuing your job hunt
using all the ken coleman tools
um the first thing that pops into my
mind because it always pops into my mind
because i'm an entrepreneur is what
could you do
that you own it
with a computer in your living room
and you could control all the variables
and control your destiny a whole lot
more
in that setting than being dependent on
someone else to
uh
make a way
for you to be able to work in their
organization
um
i don't know
have you contacted dars in your local
community the department of assisted
rehabilitat really rehabilitative
services
uh yeah so i'm actually working with a
recruiter there's a program through
social security called ticket to work
and it basically sets you up with a
recruiter who is uh familiar with
working with people with disabilities
and you know there's job coaching right
that's different
dars will help you with the computer
programs depending on your state like
they'll help you with the software to
get you the microphones the tech that
kind of stuff that you need and that can
be a real gift to to rocket launch you
out into your career man i'm proud of
you
you got a lot of courage facing this
down you're gonna get there you can help
a lot of people too you're gonna you're
gonna you're gonna you're gonna turn
into something really important don't
don't this is gonna be amazing when we
hear the end of your story
or hear further down your story thanks
for calling in that puts us hour of the
ramsey show in the books we'll be back
with you before you know it in the
meantime remember there's ultimately
only one way to financial peace and
that's to walk daily with the prince of
peace christ jesus
[Music]
this is james childs producer of the
ramsay show you can listen to all our
shows with the ramsay network app on
your smartphone browse by topic or even
sync clips to your friends
download the ramsay network app in your
favorite app store today
[Music]
you